from being almost frozen out during the
early days of the trump presidency qatar
has become a key player for joe biden
and his white house biden's foreign
policy is rather shaky he needs support
not just from large and powerful
countries like the european states
germany etc uh he needs support from
smaller but capable allies
it was qatar that hosted talks with the
taliban in doha it was qatar that played
a pivotal role as the united states
completed its chaotic withdrawal from
afghanistan it has an important link to
iran as talks about a new nuclear deal
continue
and then there's energy
as the u.s faces off against russia and
ukraine it's promising harsh sanctions
against moscow if there's an invasion
but those sanctions could be limited in
support if president putin turned off
the gas supply to europe in the middle
of winter in retaliation
the us needs another supplier and that's
where qatar and its liquid natural gas
comes in qatar is in a very good
position to supply lng
to and to do it strategically you know
it's not just for sale now you can see
in europe there's an effort to
use the production and distribution of
qatari gas in a way that strengthens the
global coalition to say to russia no you
can't invade ukraine that's not no
that's not okay
it's a very important role for qatar to
play
many of the afghan evacuees are in qatar
to be processed and as home of a massive
u.s base it will be the center of any
fresh operations in afghanistan qatar is
central not only in bandaging all the
wounds
left by you know the chaotic american
withdrawal but by uh the discussions
we're going to have to have
um to
alleviate and mitigate and address one
of the worst humanitarian crises on the
planet joe biden has signaled he doesn't
see the middle east as a priority but he
needs strategic partners in the region
and qatar zamir wants his country to be
in the prime position
to strengthen its image as a key
regional player
alan fisher al jazeera washington